mais hier l'arrêt qui paient ce qu'ils
m'ont toujours
là
après avoir marginalisés les oppositions
joseph staline opère un revirement
complet par rapport à l'aneth
la nouvelle politique économique mise en
place par lénine est appliqué au milieu
des années 20
le premier plan quinquennal instauré en
1929 oriente l'urss vers la
collectivisation totale et brutale des
campagnes et le doublement de la
production industrielle obtenue grâce à
un système administratif de commandement
le grand tournant est la première étape
de la terreur stalinienne
le choix de staline est un choix
finalement auquel se sont heurtés un
grand nombre d'hommes politiques russes
encore avant la révolution qui et
comment moderniser ce pays extrêmement
attardé et cette modernisation passe par
une industrialisation à marche forcée
qui ne peut être réalisé que sur le dos
de la paysannerie par la
collectivisation l'état peut
s'approprier sans la payer une part
grandissante de la récolte est de vendre
donc à l'étranger à la fois d'exporter
beaucoup de blé et d'importer à bon
marché des biens d'équipement pour
industrialiser le pays et donc la
terreur dirigé par staline c'est
essentiellement une terreur contre cette
immense masse de la paysannerie qui a
été exproprié mises dans des cols rose
de force et pour les paysans c'était un
traumatisme terrible puisque pour eux
c'est une sorte de second servage
la liquidation des koulaks en tant que
classe et la collectivisation qui est
presque totale au milieu des années 30
se font au prix d'un million 800 mille
et déporté le rendement agricole
s'effondre le cheptel est divisé par
deux mais les prélèvements sur la
récolte augmente et sont payés à un prix
dérisoire la famine fera six millions de
morts
madame german se souvient de la
sécheresse de 1933 en sibérie ya pa té
ni tête d'affiché sur pied et mon père
comme il y en a les a sont et il avait
son lopin donc le serbe allait de la
tapoa les gens il faut quelques années
maintenant
oui c'est ce qu'assure ce caillou dans
le pathos nos pauvres non puis à couper
du blé pour
pour nourrir encore un coffret et gb
dame d'haïti les bonnes proportions pour
essayer de faire du temps avec ses avec
ses blés parce que parce que compass pas
fait ça c'est pas de vente parce que
c'est contre compter jusqu'à le colosse
pas nous voilà bien que c'est bien
n'était pas nationalisées enfin comme on
dit mais vu la sécheresse
ils ont estimé qu' il volait donc la
communauté et il mon père elle était l
été et jusqu'à jusqu'à cinq ans la balle
est à présent nous sommes restés
appliqués ils ont fait avec nomma tout
seul pas aller les kolkhozes parce
qu'ils ne sont ne t'avais pas encore pas
quelque chose je mangerai et pata
seulement la pomme de terre est quelque
chose dont on trouvait un break simon
ledieu
quant à mirka temps aussi bien à dakar
des strikes encore de statistiques en
tout cas jusqu'à la 7e ville et
hypothermies sur tamayo attaquant
krausener voilà parce que quand
quelqu'un possède quelque chose est fait
attention
il fait plus attention consistait
communautaire
malgré la situation calamiteuse des
paysans le redressement spectaculaire de
l'urss dans les années 20 et la crise
mondiale du capitalisme de 29 amène de
nombreux intellectuels progressistes
occidentaux à s'enflammer jusqu'à
l'aveuglément pour les réalisations
soviétique et la personne de staline
dimitris esman fils d'immigrés russes
socialiste révolutionnaire et lycéens à
paris lorsque ses parents
incité par des agents soviétiques décide
de rentrer à moscou
j'étais heureux non pas parce que je
regagnais le pays de mes ancêtres mais
parce que j'allais au pays du socialisme
triomphant et comme je vous le disais je
faisais partie des jeunesses communistes
et c'était en somme le le pays
l'aboutissement de deux de tout mon
activité de mes convictions je militais
je ramassais de l'argent pour la
république espagnole
je manifesté aux cris de les soviets
partout et donc il y avait le front
populaire la guerre d'espagne tout un
climat qui finalement a conduit un
certain nombre d'émigrés à se dire en
voyant les les films soviétiques avec
des usines des ouvriers qui chantait des
des kolkhozes y un heureux et tout ça
ils ont fini par se dire mais comment
ai-je pu combattre ça comment ai-je peut
aller contre mon peuple
comment ai-je pu ne pas comprendre
qu'une vie nouvelle se construit là bas
d'autant plus qu'à côté vous avez un
romain rolland qui disait cette grande
lueur qui s'est allumé à l'est
tu parles d'une grande douleur cette
grande l'heure c'était la lgv heures des
villages ukrainien qui flambait et où
les gens mouraient de faim c'était ça la
converse seulement ça on aurait pu le
savoir nous ne voulais pas le savoir est
que depuis des camps s'ouvrait en
sibérie ou dans l'oural avec des
milliers des milliers des milliers de
gens instruits travail d'esclave et qui
m'aurait là bas nous pouvions le savoir
mais quand on nous disait nous ne
l'entendît y ont pas
la violence de la collectivisation les
ratés de la gestion administrative de la
production industrielle sont justifiées
par de supposés entreprise de sabotage
des présidents de kolkhoze des
fonctionnaires et des cadres qui doutent
des méthodes employées sont éliminés la
grande purge culmine en 1933 ou 18% des
communistes sont exclus du parti
la faiblesse des nouveaux cadres promus
la piètre formation des nouvelles
recrues ouvrière amplifie la baisse de
production et par voie de conséquence
les mesures coercitives salaire au
rendement allongement de la journée de
travail passeport intérieur
l'industrialisation accélérée plonge le
pays dans un état permanent de
mobilisation générale de tension de
chaos économique et de désordre social
le 1er décembre 1934 kirov est assassiné
à leningrad ce qui permet à staline
d'échafauder une théorie du complot dont
les premières victimes sont treize
partisans de sinnoh fief
arrêté et condamné à mort
en outre 35 le mineur stakhanov dans une
mise en scène d'opérette à bas en six
heures sans de tonnes de charbon
c'est le lancement du stakhanovisme
campagne productiviste qui multiplie les
tensions et les conflits dans les
entreprises entre une avant-garde
ouvrière supposé révolutionnaires et des
ingénieurs et techniciens supposé
réactionnaire
l'attitude versées à temps plein yamin
la granny la voie pour un sticker à
cathy l'île d'aghtamar gilani à petit
dit nice a pris d'une il est acheminé et
surtout après huit ans de guerre
patric muff faciale pourtant 2-0 dans la
série
moscou août 1936 jagoda chef de la
police politique montrent un grand
procès public où sont condamnés zinoviev
kamenev et d'anciens trotskistes grâce à
des aveux extorqués et des témoins
manipulés
tout comme dans ce procès filmé en 1930
dit procès du parti industriels ou des
ingénieurs furent condamnés pour
sabotage
les accusés compagnon de lénine s'accuse
des pires crimes se proclame assassin
saboteur traîtres et espions
tous chantent les louanges du génial
staline dans une sinistre mise en scène
réglée par le procureur vie chinsky
didier robert après sofia maliavina de
la miséricorde
il ya certes sur lequel d'ailleurs subi
des retards
surtout quand comme ailleurs pour ce
qu'ils sont
l'agencé estime michael cheika ban ki
moon sera ni souris
il ya d'ailleurs le soir sa vie se
stabilise je suis sûr qu'ils aillent sur
ce double of trouble
les amateurs de bêtes et sprite disco
picchu et des looks de fonction
lle geof qui remplace jagoda au
commissariat du peuple aux affaires
intérieures le nkvd organise suivant le
même rituel
le second procès de moscou 10 du centre
trotskiste radec piata cov sont parmi
les accusés en janvier 37
ils seront suivis par boukharine ryjkov
jagoda l'ancien chef du nkvd et 16
autres vieux bolchéviks lors du
troisième procès de mars 38 presque tous
seront exécutés ces grands procès qu'est
ce qu'on en savait on en savait ce
qu'ils avaient dans le journal et
ensuite lors des grandes manifestations
entre autres banderoles pancartes ont
porté celles où il avait écrit mort à la
vermine trotsko boukharine yen et des
choses de ceux de ce genre là quand on
est venus arrêter ma mère et mon beau
père mon frère aîné je n'étais pas là et
mémé contact avec les organismes de
répression comme on disait se sont
produits plus tard quand j'étais
étudiant c'est à ce moment là qu'on m'a
arrêté à mon tour est envoyé dans un
camp à partir du jour où on les a
emmenés
personne ne les a plus jamais vu alors
on savait qu'ils étaient en prison et on
pouvait déposer chaque mois pour frais
de cantine une somme de 75 roubles et
donc 6/7 7/6 versement était accepté ça
voulait dire qu'ils étaient encore là le
jour où on refuse et on disait nous
n'avons pas ces noms dans nos listes ça
voulait dire qu'il n'était plus là
cinquante ans plus tard lorsque on a
commencé à purin sortir et à publier
une partie des archives j'ai appris que
le procès a duré 20 minutes et ma mère
avait demandé il avait droit à une
dernière déclaration elle avait demandé
un arrêt qui table et elle a été comme
les autres condamnés à mort et exécutés
20 jours plus tard
la terreur d'état et massive généralisée
durant les deux années de ce qu'on
appellera l'ail et geof chine a des
centaines de milliers de cadres de
l'économie et du parti sont arrêtés et
condamnés 50% du comité central presque
la moitié des officiers de l'armée rouge
dont le maréchal toukhatchevski
vice-ministre de la défense
les dirigeants des républiques non russe
les militants du komintern des écrivains
musiciens cinéastes mendel stamm babel
meyerhold le zèle des activistes locaux
du nkvd dépassent les normes fixées par
le centre sept cent mille personnes sont
déportés 5 à 600 milles sont exécutés ou
disparaissent lorsque béria remplaciez
geof en décembre 38 une pause relative à
avoir lieu dans le massacre
simon movie herman juifs polonais venus
travailler quelques temps plus tôt dans
ce qu'il croyait être le paradis
socialiste est empêché de rentrer à
varsovie en 1939 et est si - fait les
prisons est donné pour un mot 1.3 hong
pour le camp républicain
la public cognaçais bon après les avec
les bagages nous sommes obligés trois
jours mais les goulags premier trois
mois c'est très difficile beaucoup y en
a beaucoup des brins à pologne il tourne
trois mois sont très forts je ne suis
pas très fort quand même et chimiques
attributs dessinait animera les attirer
tribu l'initient ligne oméraly j'ai
toujours des bugs voyons la marque chère
que celle que la première premier jour
je suis obligé alcoa dardé varsovie je
vivre avec ça vous comprenez il y en a
beaucoup de personnes visitent chef pas
réceptifs là bas nous construit semaine
vers co-prince chemin de fer quant à ce
vol coûte à 1200 km
pour tous les averses 400 morts
confirmés c'est passé vite python c
c'est pas bien tous les jours de
composer je travaille aider les blessés
je m'en veux y aller une km 3 heures
c'est fini mon trois hommes elles
peuvent aider dit arrêté jusqu'à la fin
de la guerre en serbie et en allemand
helaba
j'ai sonné kroll j'ai chanté la bonne si
je me sens de la vie vous comprenez
c'est toujours rousse ginny shanghai est
niggli les cabaniers plus bas d'août
rompons avec les thèses léniniste du
komintern staline avait imposé sa
théorie de développement du socialisme
dans un seul pays
malgré les traités signés avec la grande
bretagne et la france à la suite des
accords de munich de 1938 il cherche à
temporiser avec hitler et charges
molotov des négociations l'aboutissement
en est la signature avec von ribbentrop
à moscou le 23 août 39 du pacte germano
soviétique ribbentrop qui arrive à
moscou en première page de la pravda
on le voit molotov et lui signant le
pacte derrière le camarade staline ça
pis pour beck souriant et en bas le
texte du tos qu'il porte à la santé dit
claire le soir même en disant nous
savons l'affection que le peuple
allemand porte à son führer
je me fichais comment tout cela est-il
possible
et puis pire encore 1940
je me dis enfin les choses rentrent dans
l'ordre
la france et l'allemagne se font la
guerre verdun va recommencer et la
france va être victorieuse et tout ça je
retrouverai enfin
repères et la radio me lie le télégramme
de félicitations adressé par molotov à
hitler pour la prise de sa fille c'est
l'effondrement de 2 to je ne sais plus à
quoi me raccrocher à quoi pourrait je me
raccrocher mes parents sont mis en
prison par le régime auquel ils
s'étaient dévoués corps et âme
ce régime socialiste fait des mamours à
un horrible régime nazi que comment
comment puis-je voir tout ça sans
devenir cinglé les clauses secrètes du
pacte germano-soviétique permettent à l'
urss dès 1939 de récupérer la majorité
des territoires de l'ex empire russe
perdue dans les années 20 pologne
orientale états baltes carélie
bessarabie depuis la deuxième chose
c'était de gagner un peu de temps face à
un affrontement juger quand même
probable avec l'allemagne nazie
étant donné que toutes les tentatives
faites avec d'accord avec les puissances
occidentales avec la france la grande
bretagne en particulier au cours de
l'été 39 et même avant avait s'était
soldée par un échec à cause notamment de
l'hostilité du gouvernement polonais
mais le 22 juin 1941 les armées nazies
envahissent le territoire soviétique et
ne sont arrêtés que dans les faubourgs
de moscou
il y avait bien sûr des raisons disons
strictement militaire mais plus
profondément il y à une désorganisation
de l'armée rouge des cadres de l'armée
rouge à la suite des purges de 1937 38
et plus profondément il y a des ferments
de dissension très fort entre les
soldats essentiellement paysans qui
quelque part en vol quand même à ce
système parce que ce sont des kolkhozes
y un bon avec un système extrêmement
impopulaire encore dans les campagnes
donc tous ceux ci sont roux tant de
raisons qui expliquent que ce cette
catastrophe militaire de l'été 41
l'armée allemande avance jusqu'à l'été
42 et atteint les portes de leningrad ou
stalingrad et la mer caspienne
les centres économiques et industriels
sont évacués vers l'oral et l'asie
centrale
quarante pour cent de la population
soviétique vit sous occupation nazie
la guerre était terrible les privations
et est épouvantable et pourtant des gens
des hommes surtout disait c'était le bon
temps
les choses sont un peu revenus à leur
place avant au moment de la terreur on
leur disait de se méfier de tout le
monde et que ton voisin qui te semble
très gentil c'est peut être un ennemi du
peuple alors méfie toi
et là tout d'un coup il y avait un
ennemi qui était un vrai ennemi et qu'on
pouvait haïr librement
le sursaut est aussi fort que le
désarroi des premiers mois ont certes
s'il se matérialise à stalingrad il a
commencé bien avant
je pense que l'expérience de la barbarie
nazie qui est apparu très vite très
clairement a joué un rôle fondamental
dans ce sursaut patriotique
l'autre facteur du sursaut c'est que
staline est arrivé à identifier la cause
du régime avec celle de la patrie et
ceux ci l'a fait très habilement dans
son discours radiodiffusé du 3 juillet
1941 lorsque il a d'emblée placé ce
combat pour la survie du peuple russe et
pour cela d'ailleurs il
cesser momentanément les persécutions
contre les lys orthodoxe qui a donné sa
caution morale pour cette guerre
patriotique cette cause sacrée
il ne s'agissait plus du régime
soviétique
il s'agissait plus de défendre les les
beautés du socialisme
il s'agissait d'une défense biologique
de de la nation du corps de la nation et
c'est ce qui explique stalingrad
stalingrad à ressembler à rien d'autre
chaque mot chaque étage de chaque maison
faisait l'objet de combats acharnés
on n'a pas voulu ici il semble que la
nation a dit non on ne peut pas les
fruits
je ne sais pas parce qu'il faut les
arrêter c'est pas passé il s'était sur
la volga la volga qui est quelque chose
d'hors presque d'emblématique pour pour
le russe ce c'était de la grande artère
ou couler le sang du pays de d'un bout à
l'autre
il ya des chansons des les jantes et
tout d'un coup les allemands étaient là
c'était pas possible la victoire de
stalingrad en février 43 marque le début
de la défaite allemande partisans
soviétique et armés range regagner le
terrain perdu à yalta en crimée en
février 45 staline roosevelt et
churchill organise l'après guerre
l'occupation de l'europe et
particulièrement de l'allemagne y est
planifié les frontières de la pologne
remodelé l urss obtient 3 sièges à l'onu
pour la russie l'ukraine et la
biélorussie
l'armée rouge atteint berlin le 2 mai
1945 l'allemagne nazie capitule le 9 mai
bien sûr l'avancé extrême de l'armée
rouge jusqu'à berlin a créé une
situation géopolitique tout à fait
inédit tout à fait différente
à l'issue de la guerre il y à la fois ce
sentiment d'être une très grande
puissance avec la plus grande armée
conventionnelle du monde d'être une
puissance victorieuse mais en même temps
paradoxalement encore un très fort
sentiment de vulnérabilité
parce qu'elle n'avait pas les armes
atomiques
les américains et aussi à cause des
immenses destructions de la guerre avec
ayant perdu plus de 26 millions de
civils et de militaires avec des
destructions absolument considérable
sans commune mesure avec ce qui avait
connu l'europe occidentale